now it may look a bit intimidating
especially because I've asked Shannon
just to give us the bare bones of the
question so there's not much context
around this or just like what what does
this even mean
okay so up here you've got sort of
notation overload you have a function
hence the name but we define it in
different ways for different values of X
so usually you're used to something like
this which means that let's let's do
this no matter what X you throw in you
only have to interpret that value of x
or evaluate it for a single function
that's what this function is all the
time that's kind of what's implied but
here this is like a function that kind
of changes its clothes every now and
then depending on the time of day so
it's like a right out of Chinese wedding
you can see for these values of X this
is what you're gonna do for these values
of X this is what you're gonna do and so
on okay so you actually have to kind of
read it in Reverse from right to left
you have a look at the value you're
interested in you go through the
appropriate spot and then you evaluate
whatever function is related to that
okay so the first one the first question
just says what is f of two what is f of
2 so like I mentioned before you go
start from the right hand side and have
a look at which one of these domains
does your chosen value fall into okay so
just be careful because if you look
closely you'll see that you've got these
boundaries sometimes you counterbattery
and sometimes you don't and so you can
see two is going to fall into this
bottom one do you see how that's
included or is it's excluded in this one
above so you can't just look for the
number you've also got to look for which
weight is my boundary go okay so being
that it is in this part I'm going to
evaluate this function for this value so
I'm going to just do the substitution
this is 8 minus 2 squared which is 8
minus 4 which is 4 okay by the way don't
skip that step it's I know very simple
numerically but what it shows is I can
see where this is come from I can see
that it's some you're actually
evaluating this and you're
substitution even if it's just simple
numbers it demonstrates understanding
okay so the next question is sketch now
once you've got this underway you then
want to piece together what does the
rest of it look like being that I
already did this last one I might as
well start by having a look at this bit
first so I'm doing everything in Reverse
at the moment so here's my set of axes I
don't know anything about what this is
gonna look like yet but I can see that
for this little portion over here
so from here to three up to four and
that's what it ends it doesn't keep on
going forever this is the graph that I
want 8 minus x squared
just picture 8 minus x squared for a
second forget about the rest of it just
imagine what 8 minus x squared would
look like if that was the only thing you
drew here what key told me about the
shape yeah yep good so parabola it's
concave down it's facing downwards and
it's being shifted which direction has
been shifted in yeah up eight units so
you can sort a picture here do you have
you got the picture sort of in your mind
but of course you're not going to draw
the whole thing you can draw the whole
thing
you're only gonna draw this bit okay now
remember I'm sort of tasting at this
shape like so where is it going to begin
it'll begin at x equals two somewhere
over here and I've got a y-value for
that do you see that so I'm gonna mark
that in if I go x equals two one two
and I'm gonna go y equals four so one
two three four I'm gonna put a filled
circle here because I know that's where
I begin okay
I don't do anything to the left because
that is not within this domain I go a
little bit to the right so now I don't
want to know where does this end when X
is equal to 4 what will f of X be equal
to whatever for a look
it'll be eight minus four squared eight
minus four squared which is eight take
away sixteen so it's gonna be all the
way down here at negative eight
does that make sense so I'm actually
going to need to change my scale a
little bit because I don't know
non-space let's make this four so that's
negative 2 negative 4 negative 8
negative 16 you care with that see how
I'm piecing things together so that's it
x equals 4 okay how does it look so far
that's all right now I see that from
here to here remember you had the
general shape in your mind clearly I'm
gonna pass through the x-axis so I
probably want to find that intercept how
do I do that I'm going to let y equal 0
down here yeah and when you let y equal
0 for this guy you get x squared equals
8 you notice that so if x squared is 8
then X is the square root of 8 what is
the square root of 8 roughly anyway is
it between 2 & 3 or 3 & 4 it's between 2
& 3 right cuz this is our root 4 and
this is root 9 root 8 must be somewhere
in here so I'm just going to draw it
roughly like so and call that root 8
how are you handling so far okay this is
just a bit of a parabola but we're so
used to drawing an entire parabola that
you have to do a bit of extra thinking
to make sure you work out what's going
on by the way what do we got down here
negative 16 is that what I said I want
negative 8 to 9 I was counting the wrong
way it's in the right spot I put a
filled circle down here why don't put a
filled circle that good you can look at
you can see the boundary that one's
included right it doesn't have to be I
could have been asked to draw that in
which case there would have been a
hollow circle over there but I was asked
to draw this so far so good so we've
done one portion in fact when I go
through this question I like to tick off
little portions here and there so I know
what's going on now I'm over to this
portion I'm just gonna go from right to
left to keep going so from negative 1 to
2 this is what the graph looks like from
negative 1
- hmm so again just like here I'm gonna
think about where I start and where I
end where's that where I end so when X
is equal to negative 1 what is the
function equal to what is f of negative
1 so this is a bit of a trick question
isn't it
because when F is equal to negative 1
I'm actually not even in this domain
do you see that I mean this one but I
would be if I could evaluate that I
would be at y equals negative 1 so I'm
gonna put a hollow circle there because
I'm not actually there does that make
sense so what are we saying this is
negative 2 so negative 1 would be around
here here's my hollow circle okay are
you right with that that's negative 1
sorry my scales are different but that
way I can fit all my numbers on okay so
that's where I begin and then I'm going
to go up like y equals x would expect
you to and where am I going to end what
coordinates will I end at at 2 comma 2
right 2 comma 2
there's x equals 2 and y equals 2 and as
you predict you're going right through
so I forgive my terrible graph there
you're passing right through the origin
ok because it's y equals x yeah you use
a ruler and make that look better than
mine last portion over here middle
portion I've got the one on the left it
looks weird but that's because it's
defined in all these kinds of different
ways so now take that guy off I'm it's
the last one x squared minus 1 forget
about the rest of it for a second do you
have a picture of x squared minus 1 in
your mind you know what it looks like
it's a concave up parabola and it's been
shifted down a unit so it's sort of like
a like this right it begins at x equals
well sort of here at x equals negative 1
what will this guy be equal to when X is
negative 1 0 I'm gonna put a filled
circle there and then how far do I need
to go it doesn't go forever does it it
goes all the way up to negative 4
so when x equals negative for what I put
into here will be negative for all
squared which is 16 take away 1 which is
15 okay where's 15 going to be huh okay
it's I think I'm gonna be about here I'd
say so no give 1 negative 2 negative 3
negative 4 oh that's filled what do you
think if I completed the rest of the
parabola you can see where it belongs so
I've got my coordinates here and they're
done so it's a strange beast but that's
sort of exactly what you expect because
look it just keeps on changing it's
worse than Jekyll and Hyde it's like
three different things all the different
times so none of these have anything to
do with each other and that's why you
have all these weird discontinuities
here in the middle okay but remember
think about how I went through this
step-by-step I look at the domain and
then I think about what does this graph
look like where does it start and where
does it end okay